the movie opens in 1967 where a pregnant
woman is being rushed to a hospital she
is severely bleeding from the neck
appearing as if she was attacked by some
kind of animal the doctors perform an
emergency C-section and save the baby
but sadly the woman dies the scene then
shifts to 30 years later and we are
introduced to a young man named Dennis
who is in the car with his girlfriend
she takes him to an underground
nightclub located somewhere in Los
Angeles as they enter the club everyone
begins to stare at Dennis in a creepy
way just then the sprinklers present
there starts showering blood boom boom
all the party goers enjoy it and they
cheer in happiness but Dennis goes into
a state of panic this is when we realize
that all the people inside the club are
actually vampires slowly they turn their
attention towards Dennis and proceed to
attack him but in the nick of time our
protagonist blade arrives at the scene
clad and a black leather outfit turns
out blade is the same child from the
opening scene who has now become a
vampire hunter the vampires launched
their attack on blade but he easily
defeats them using his special weapons
eventually all the vamps are either dead
or have fled except for Quinn a muscular
vampire he tries to Ambush blade but
instead gets burnt to a crisp seconds
later the cops arrive at the scene so
blade casually walks away in the next
scene the police transport Quinn's burnt
body to a local hospital where a morgue
technician named Curtis and a
hematologist Dr Karen Jensen conduct an
examination on it they discover numerous
irregularities including abnormally
developed jaw muscles as they discuss
the test results
suddenly comes back to life and attacks
both the doctors the vampire immediately
bites Curtis to death but before he can
do the same to Karen blade shows up he
effortlessly cuts off one of Quinn's
arms prompting him to run away blade
then takes Karen to his safe house where
his old associate Abraham Whistler tends
to her injuries Abraham administers her
with a solution of garlic Essence and
silver nitrate expressing a cautious
optimism about her chances of recovery
estimating them at 50 50. elsewhere we
see a group of vampires discussing
Blade's recent attack on their fellow
members one of the young vampires named
Deacon Frost wants the vampires to
outright rule the humans and simply use
them as a food source while an older
vampire named dragonetti prefers to
maintain a peaceful coexistence
dragonetti does not seem to like frost
because he is not a pure blood as he
merely became a vampire through the bite
of another the next morning Karen wakes
up and wanders around the safe house
during this she Witnesses Abraham
injecting Blade with some blood serum
later on Abraham explains that he and
blade have been waging a secret war
against vampires using weapons based on
their Elemental weaknesses such as
sunlight silver and garlic or in the
case of Blade taxis as Karen is now
marked by the bite of a vampire both he
and blade urge her to leave the city
afterwards Karen goes to her apartment
and begins packing her belongings as she
prepares to leave she is confronted by a
police officer named Krieger who is a
human slave owned by a vampire Krieger
tries to attack her but blade once again
comes to her rescue he effortlessly
subdues the corrupt cop and notices a
tattoo on the back of his neck blade
immediately recognizes it as the mark of
Deacon Frost he then lets Krieger go in
the hopes of tracking him to another
vampire Club following this blade and
Karen's Shadow Krieger to a new
Underground club there they come across
a morbidly obese vampire named Pearl who
works as a Record Keeper they torture
him with a UV light demanding that he
give up information at first the
pustulant freak of nature refuses saying
he'd rather die than snitch but as soon
as the UV light starts burning his skin
he speaks up Pearl reveals that Frost
wants to command a ritual where he would
use 12 pure-blooded vampires to awaken
the blood God La magra armed with this
Insight the duo delves further into the
vampire archives housing Pages extracted
from the vampire Bible not long after
they find themselves ambushed by a
faction of vampires led by Quinn who is
now healed and regrown as previously
severed hand Quinn is determined to
exact Vengeance but he soon realizes
that blade has a radio link in his ear
moments later Abraham arrives at the
scene and opens fire on the vampires in
the midst of the chaos blade cuts off
the other hand of Quinn seizing an
opportune moment the trio then boards a
passing subway car making their escape
returning to the safeass Abraham reveals
the complete backstory of Blade to Karen
he recounts that he found blade on the
streets feeding upon homeless people
according to Abraham blade is a unique
amalgamation of human and vampire traits
possessing the supernatural strength of
vampires without any of their weaknesses
except for the need to consume human
blood Abraham also reveals that he's
been developing serums to curb Blade's
Cravings but Blade's body is starting to
resist it the same evening Abraham
learns that his attempt to cure Karen
was ineffective and that she is growing
close to turning into a vampire despite
this Karen refuses to give up so she
heads to the hospital where she used to
work and brings some laboratory
equipment in order to try and find a
cure for both her and blade while
experimenting with the anticoagulant
EDTA as a potential substitute she
discovers that it has a violent reaction
when it is mixed with vampire blood
recognizing its potential she gives it
to Blade envisioning it as a potent
weapon against the vampires meanwhile
Quinn is at the vampire base facing
reprimand for his repeated failures
Frost orders him to go back out and
capture blade alive this confuses Quinn
as his boss and all other vampires have
been trying to kill blade for a very
long time but so far none have succeeded
afterwards Frost and his henchmen abduct
dragonetti and take him to a beach Just
Before Sunrise they forcibly rip out the
Elder vampire's fangs while Frost and
his gangs Shield themselves with
sunscreen black clothing and motorcycle
helmets it's so 90s it hurts then Dragon
Eddie is Left To Burn to death due to
the sun's Rays after this Frost
confronts the remaining Elders of the
vampire Council demanding that 12 people
volunteer for his La magra project in
the next scene his blade goes to
purchase more items for hunting Abraham
and Karen discuss her latest attempt to
cure vampire bites Karen is sure that
the new formula will work on her but she
is unsure what effects it might have on
blade because of his vampiric nature
nonetheless she remains Resolute in her
belief that she can cure his blood
thirst even if the process will take
years as the two continue chatting Frost
and his men suddenly barge inside their
safe house Abraham tries to shoot them
with his special gun but he is easily
overwhelmed and beaten up the bad guys
then kidnap Karen and flee the scene a
short time later blade returns home only
to discover Abraham in a vegetative
state he is on the verge of dying due to
the vampiric infection in his final
moments he reveals about Frost's La
magra project detailing that he is in
search of Blade's blood Abraham then
requests blade be careful saying the
existence of humanity depends on him
after this he grabs Blade's gun and
commits the unthinkable fearing that he
will turn into a vampire consumed by
Fury blade infiltrates Frost's
headquarters and kills all of his men
any of them who come in his way he
attacks the vampires with EDTA which
makes them swell up and explode in a
shower of blood and Prosthetics blade
finally reaches Frost's office where he
is confronted by a woman she calls him
by the name Eric indicating that she
knows him well then in a shocking
revelation we get to know that the woman
is none other than Blade's mother who
has been reborn as a vampire and has
been serving for frost while blade is
distracted by this Revelation Frost and
his men show up and hold him hostage it
is at this moment when Frost reveals
himself as the vampire who bit his
mother while she was pregnant that's
right I'm your dad after this blade and
Karen are confined within a dark cell
during this blade asks Karen if she is
finished with her experiment with a
miracle cure in response she explains
that The Cure if successful would
presumably take away all of his strength
and healing powers however it would also
neutralize his bloodthirst effectively
turning him into a complete human
shortly after blade is subdued and taken
to the Temple of Eternal Night where
Frost plans to perform the summoning
ritual for La magra meanwhile Karen is
thrown into a pit intended to be
devoured by her former colleague Curtis
who has now transformed into a
decomposing zombie-like creature Curtis
launches an assaults on her but Karen
manages to fight back and somehow
Maneuvers her escape from the pit she's
giving a great name to Karen's all
around the world in the next scene blade
is put into a large torture device where
his blood is extracted as the ritual
initiates 12 members of the council are
executed and their souls are absorbed by
Frost turning into La magra the blood
God a while later Karen manages to free
blade from the torture device but he now
appears to be very weak realizing that
there is only one way to get Blade
healed in time Karen asks him to drink
her blood he resists at first but seeing
no other choice I guess if you're really
gonna twist my arm he finally sucks at
the blood from her neck blade is revived
in no time and seems to be stronger than
ever however Frost completes the ritual
by this time securing the might of La
magra before confronting Frost Blade's
mother suddenly shows up and fights him
while blade is on the brink of ending
her life she tries to manipulate him
emotionally invoking the maternal Bond
however blade doesn't fall for her trick
and ultimately strikes her with a fatal
blow ending her life he then fights his
way through the remaining vampire guards
reclaiming his trademark sword and also
decapitating Quinn to reclaim his
sunglasses in the meantime Karen also
helps blade in taking out some of the
Vampires by using the garlic mace
causing them to explode after a while
blade finally comes face to face with
frost and an intense battle ensues
between the two swords clash with
impressive precision as they engage in
combat at one point played Sever's
Frost's arm and slices him in half but
the blood God's body takes no time to
regenerate when nothing else Works blade
grabs the packet of EDTA vials and hurls
them all towards Frost administering
multiple injections across his body the
plan works and as a consequence of the
EDTA overdose Frost's body swells up and
explodes in a massive shower of blood
finally resulting in his demise blade
does a cool Victory pose and says
science Rules in the aftermath of this
event Karen extends an offer to cure
blade but he declines reasoning that
despite Frost's demise there are many
other vampires out there and that he
must finish all of them blade tells her
that if she really wants to help him she
can create an improved version of this
serum so that he can continue his
Crusade against vampire fires in the
final sequence we see blade confronting
a vampire in Moscow subscribe for more
videos like this turn on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching